Joe Biden's press secretary Michael L
Roa was just forced out of the White
House after he apparently tried quote
tried to take gay dates to his room on a
secure floor of the hotel where the
president was staying during a NATO
Summit in Madrid so when we say dates
we're not talking about this is a man
who had been cultivating some sort of
relationship over some weeks and months
no it was a guy who like went on an app
or something or met a guy at a bar and
this this press secretary for the first
lady of the United States brings some
random dude back to the secured floor
where the president of the United States
is staying uh to go engage in weird
stuff that apparently happens in places
other than the US capital I I am calling
for a complete and total shutdown of
homosexual political staffers with
iPhones until we figure out what the
hell is going on okay I am a complete
and total shutdown we should not be
reading this many headlines within the
span of two weeks at very high levels of
the government